2,000 Marines and sailors are being
deployed to Israeli Waters and they're
being prepared for a potential
deployment into the country at the same
time Janet Yellen reassures all of us
yes the United States can afford two
Wars and don't worry when Joe Biden was
asked on 60 Minutes he also confirmed
come on we're the most powerful nation
in the history not not just the world
the history of the world we can handle
it they're gearing up for for a major
escalation of War and the argument is is
that by sending the troops in it will
prevent War but uh let's let's be real
if the US actually deploys Ground Forces
into Israel wow talk about a dramatic
escalation at a time we've already been
seeing attacks from Syria in Israel
Lebanon and Israel back and forth
there's now threats from Lindsey Graham
Lindsey Graham says that we should bomb
Iran with or without
evidence I hope you guys are ready for
the war that they're about to start